before i get to audience questions the
last question i have well two i want to
know what you think is the difference
between wisdom and intelligence and then
i wanted to know what you thought of
wigner's friends
figner's friends thought experiment or
the thought experiment of vigner's
friend i'm sure you've heard of it about
the collapse of the wave function
yeah so
first with respect to intelligence and
wisdom there is a very
big difference between them wisdom
is the ability to to identify the
essential
uh elements
uh necessary to to answer questions and
and learn about about the world
um so
it's a way of improving the efficiency
of us
figuring out the truth you know and
someone
that is wise gives you a shortcut
you can be very intelligent and just
examine all the exits from the highway
many of them would lead you into bad
neighborhoods
but if you are wise you will try to
figure out which exit is the right one
and
so
so
intelligence
may be
an essential skill
in pursuing science
and you can become a world expert in a
particular niche
just like taking an exit from the
highway in that exit you can become
the world expert
but it's not necessarily the niche that
matters the most
and if you are wise
you can figure out which niche matters
the most
if you're wise how do you determine
which one matters
which one is the right one i imagine
that depends on the goal but then i'm
wondering well how do you decide on the
goal you have just what allows you to
survive you have to decide about the
guiding principles first so
for example
to some people what matters the most are
subjects of relevance to society
you know if it has an impact on society
because after all we live in a society
you know and
whether we address um
how many extra dimensions exist or
whether we address how to find a vaccine
to covet 19 or
um you know these are two different
questions with very different
impacts on society
so
you might use that when you evaluate
what you want to do if you want to help
people
then you work on some
questions that matter to them now it
doesn't mean that they all have to be
medical
they could be questions that people care
about
right right so um in that way
since the public is funding science
you are paying respect to the public
if on the other hand you ask yourself
how many angels can sit on the tip of a
pin
and you get funded by the public
and then you say i don't care what the
public says and i don't care if i have
experiments to test my ideas
then that's a betrayal of the trust that
the society has in academia
and that is a good reason for the public
to say
that
you know academia is part of the elite
because because it's divorcing itself
from the interests of the public
so
being wise is attending
to the interests of those who found fund
you
that's an example